someone told me you're getting into
farming yes
i'm a farmer i have tomatoes cherry
tomatoes and heirlooms
and now my cherry tomatoes they are
giving me a pretty fruitful
bounty i'm having lovely harvests just a
real treat
my heirlooms on the other hand i am not
getting a fruitful bounty
my harvests are very small and few in
between i also have a watermelon that i
grew incorrectly
too much rind not enough meat my
cucumbers
one was good one got all effed up messed
up
and then uh the other one died um and
then
my carrots i don't know what i'm doing
they're not thriving
um what else do i have oh i got peppers
that just won't grow
okay this is what i'm gonna say here's
the effect of quarantine on you nicole
over the years you and i have spoken
many times and you always talk at great
length about
your um well raunchy sex life
uh sexual matters you're very explicit
about um uh gentlemen that you've hooked
up with
and uh you go into great detail and i
get very embarrassed
now after almost a year of quarantine
you're talking about
tomatoes and carrots and how they're not
thriving is this the new is this the new
nicole buyer
no no no no no when
life goes back to normal which it will i
will
hop back on the dicks and i will be
riding them all day long
i cannot wait but for right now as a
lady who's scared of corona
and refuses to die for mediocre
things like my cucumbers my carrots
i was told zucchinis are good growers so
i might get some zucchinis
but it's getting it's getting to be a
lot but i think that because you're
getting into this farming language that
when you get into dating again
you're going to talk about your dating
life but you're going to be using
farming terminology you're going to be
saying like well
lately i've been dating a penis is not
thriving they're not thriving they're
not developing i don't know what the
problem is
this penis is not ready to harvest
i don't think it's ready right now